[موسيقى]
كتابي يُدعى 13 امرأة رائعة من
الجزيرة العربية وهو يتحدث عن هؤلاء
النساء العربيات الـ 13 اللواتي ألهمنني حفزني
طوال طفولتي لأصبح
أفضل نسخة ممكنة من نفسي
كتبت عنها لأنني شعرت
على الرغم من أنني شعرت طوال طفولتي
وكأنهم لم يحصلوا على
الاعتراف الذي يستحقونه
في حياتهم المهنية وفي حياتهم
بشكل عام وأردت فقط
تسليط بعض الضوء عليهم لأنه
يستحق
في رأيي.  لدي أي
أشخاص أساسيين في الكتاب لأنني اخترت هؤلاء
النساء الـ 13 على وجه التحديد
لأنهن من ألهمنني
طوال طفولتي
وهن أولئك الذين دائمًا ما
يمثلون قصصهم وكل ما حدث
وإنجازاتهم التي طالما وقفوا عليها
أكثر من غيرهم ، وأود أن أقول
إنهم جميعًا الأشخاص الرئيسيون لأنه من بين
جميع
النساء الرائعات الأخريات اللائي حققن
الكثير من الأشياء الرائعة ،
اخترت هذه الأشياء 13.
لذا أود أن أقول إن  إن
أكثر ما يثيرني هو
قصة نورا وغابي
لأنها في الواقع وزيرة الثقافة
وتنمية المعرفة ،
كما أنني كنت دائمًا مهتمًا جدًا
بالسياسة والعلوم السياسية
وكل ذلك وأريد بالفعل
انخرط في السياسة في المستقبل
وأصبحت دبلوماسية ، لذلك أود أن أقول
إن
قصتها أثارت حماستي
بالتأكيد وهناك قصة أخرى
كتبتها عن إيما كلوني
وأود أن أقول إن قصتها أثارتني
كثيرًا لأنها من حقوق الإنسان
المحامية وكل ما تفعله هو أمر لا
يصدق
وهي قريبة جدًا من والدتها وهي
تتحدث دائمًا عن والدتها كيف أن
والدتها هي قدوتها وأنا أجد
هذا الأمر
مرتبطًا بي لأن والدتي هي
بالتأكيد قدوتي وأنا
بالتأكيد أتطلع إلى أن أكون مثلها في
المستقبل
[موسيقى]
شخصيًا ، لا يهمني حقًا
أين سيذهب كتابي في المستقبل ،
أنا فخور جدًا
وسعداء بذلك  أعطيت
الفرصة للكتابة عن هؤلاء النساء
الرائعات وأم إذا تمكنت على طول الخط من
إلهام
الفتيات الصغيرات
لأن هذا كتاب أطفال
تعرفين أنهن أنفسهن ويذهبن إلى
المجال الذي يرغبن فيه ومن ثم
فهذا رائع أيضًا
[موسيقى]